if you don't know
jenna and jason derulo um dated then
they had this adorable little baby so
the two of them break up and jenna
decides to take this to the internet she
says women don't deserve to be treated
and judged the way they are no one
aspires to be a single mom
it's the biggest heartbreak and failure
for me personally knowing i'm alone in
this
when i wanted love and wanted marriage
and the happy family uni unit but if
you're non-negotiables are being tested
you'll never find peace in that
relationship there's nothing in life i
want more than my family to be together
but i can't be the only one working to
make that happen if a man wants to be
with a different girl every week over
his family i'll never accept that we
will never be able to make it work
happily i've been straight up told that
i should turn the other cheek i'll never
be okay with sharing a lover that i love
with all of my heart i don't receive
child support all i ever wanted was a
family to love and experience life with
with if the streets come first i can't
change that so stop blaming women like
we choose to be choose the single mother
life that is hella annoying you don't
know what women go through to try to
make it work it was never about money or
dating someone famous i loved we planned
to have a baby and the life together it
didn't work out life must go on leave me
alone okay so let me give my take on
this oh gosh so jason droulo is famous
he's handsome he is surrounded by
beautiful women constantly and you know
this when you guys start dating you know
this what are the odds that a guy is
handsome rich famous and also going to
be faithful to you if you want to date
guys on that high of a level if you want
to be a part of that life that is what
usually comes with it now i know there
are exceptions but it is not the rule
most men if they have beautiful models
wanting to sleep with them all the time
at some point they're probably going to
give in and do it i'm sorry
so your options are either to date
someone less famous less handsome and
they won't cheat on you or go for those
guys and they probably will like i am
just so tired of women
acting like the victims and acting like
they didn't know what they were getting
into like uh what you really thought
jason derulo was gonna be faithful to
you why why would you think that and i
know being cheated on sucks it's not a
fun experience but you're making a child
with a man before you're married knowing
he's an international celebrity
knowing he probably has never been
faithful to a girl ever and acting
shocked he cheats on you like come on
i'm just tired of us playing the victim
you knew you knew what you were getting
yourself into